When I say pickle Rick, what is the first thing that comes to your mind? Be honest. Pickle. Rick.
Isaac...
Newton
Pickle...
Rick.
Socrates.
Pickle...
Rick!
Pickle...Pickle
[Laughter]
[voice intensifies] Mark Zuckerberg...
Pickle Rick!
Katy Perry!
The greatest creation of our time, of our generation, this is what...
...they will speak of when they look back at our time.
Today we're gonna play pickle Rick the game.
"The game"  everybody... "They" made a game.
"They" made a game called 'Piccle Ricc'.
It's 100% approved by...
[it's not approved]
...Adult Swim they- they made this game this game is made by them.
[sarcasm]
Uhhh...
This game will cost you four dollars on Steam.
Here we go. I am pickle Rick. It says "Thug Life" on me.
Excellent. Okay, here's our first enemy the rat. It says "kill".
This is incredible... look at that!
Oh my god the graphics! He doesn't know where I am now.
This is just like pickle Rick.
There we go the rat is kill. It has merged with the floor.
...and there it is, pickle Rick. That's my name. I'm pickle Rick! [Rick voice]
Press Q or B to break vases. Oh my god. Just like Dark Souls! [suddenly realizes]
Just. Like. Dark. Souls [yelling]
Open chest.
[yells] It's just like Dark Souls!
I have a sword just like...
[thinks out loud] Is this Dark Souls?
Yes. This must be. I feel... I just feel my IQ points going up every time.
Now this... this is what I'm talking about. This is... now this is a soundtrack...
...we recognize! Now let's roll through these to break them...
[realizes you can't break them]
As instructed. That doesn't seem to work.
That's fine.
This is just like half-life. Look at these...uhh. I'm gonna go in a stealth approach here.
as pickle Rick always do.
This is so fun.
[sarcasm]
I can roll too, just like Dark Souls.
They don't seem to hit back.
[punches missing again and again]
[spastic clicking of mouse]
This is the hardcore adrenaline rush that I want from video games
Truly inspirational.
I've always wanted to be pickle Rick because he always goes..."I'm Pickle Rick!"
So now I know what that feels like.
I'm dead.
[music stops]
...and the rat continues to stare at the wall.
ahhh...
"Resume" resumes the game. Okay.
[intense metal music resumes]
All right, we got a great sword. Now let's mess these boys up!
Look at that just like pickle Rick. Whoa! Look at that zombie's crazy!
Knock em' out.
Thug life am I right? The sword is going through my head.
Wonderful.
I'm so glad that Adult Swim and the team of Rick and Morty really put the time and effort to make a...
...decent game and not just live off the meme...
...and live off the franchise.
This is really what gamers want.
There's a checkpoint here for some reason.
I think we're ready for this bad boy...
[in Spartan voice] This. Is. Pickle...
...Rick. [fails to pull off a quick meme]
I was trying to "this is SPARTAA" him...
but uhh...
Maybe we can do a jump attack on this guy!
[heavenly singing voices]
[huge fail]
I think we did it.
This does... feel a lot like Dark Souls. You can't-
You can't argue against that.
Here we are now in the second level, which we do recognize from Rick and Morty itself.
[sarcasm]
You have experienced a shipwreck. [giggles]
Just like pickle Rick... I mean Rick and Morty! "Find necessary tools or working ship to escape this planet"
Just like Rick and Morty! This game is on Steam.
We've got a lightsaber katana everyone.
Excellent.
Wonderful.
You know all these their Dark Souls clones that come out. It's a shame...
They should have just made this and not even bother
We're fighting Zz-Cyborgs now?
Just. Like. Rick and Morty.
[sarcasm]
Looks like we're about to face some more enemies.
[notices music stopped] Is the music not looping?
It's not looping is it? It's not looping it. It just stops.
[chuckles]
The music just stops, which sends a deeper meaning on how...
...things just doesn't go on forever everything has a time...
[lacks IQ points to say something deep]
...set of things. Okay. I'm a Rick and Morty fan. So you would only understand if you...
[IQ depleted]
"it"
There we go we killed another one of the cyborgs, now we're gonna continue our quest up here...
I am having the time of my life. There's no other game I would rather play right now.
This is it guys.
This is- we-we- this is officially. Oh wow that looks like a lot of enemies.
Oh wow, this is gonna be a tough one for pickle Rick.
I wish we had a save for once... they f---in' put them everywhere.
umm...
[incomprehensible]
[more IQ points needed]
Ohh! I insta-died man. That's tough man.
[Feels bad man]
It just...
Okay.
[winded exhale]
It's a challenge this game. You know the developers didn't want it to be easy
Which I can respect you know and... I lose my weapon apparently if I respawn.
That is f---ing great.
All right we're gonna do- We're gonna do a new approach here.
Since we don't have any weapon, because it just doesn't load your weapon...
...we're gonna- We're gonna do a new approach called. "You only live once a once" [Y.O.L.O.]
...and it seems to be working just fine! [laugher]
Oh wow that was quite the threat that we had there...
Let's continue. Wow we beat the level!
What level is going to present itself next? My god. Okay. This is nice-
This is nice "Your teleport has broken, but you really need to return back to your own dimension"
Yeah, like how the game tells me that.
"Find right equipment and make sure that you can leave". Okay, all right, okay?
Are you an enemy or...?
[Spongebob meme] "Hey buddy you need a ride? I was just on my way to the..."
I'm must not going to bother...
Look a checkpoint!
Right away. That's just great.
This happens in Dark Souls 2. You try and hit the goddamn monster, but you keep hitting the...
F---ing doorway, and it's so annoying! This is just like Dark Souls which I really appreciate
[screaming man meme]
You-you-you tell me this is not like Dark Souls.
Okay, you tell me. Oh my god.
Could you be wandering aimlessly into an empty map or are you going in the right path? You know that's...
...that's the questions you ask yourself.
While playing this game, which sorta makes you reflect on life as well
Are you just wandering aimlessly, or are you on the right path... [chuckles] in life?
And is that lens flare going to f---ing f--k off?
It's so annoying.
These stairs are very well designed for pickle Rick. They're so well designed that
It's truly an intellectual challenge...
...to enter these stairs. Why would I walk up the stairs you might ask yourself?
I mean the graph- the graphics is some of the best- The best we've ever seen.
[sarcasm]
Okay, let's see if we can do a stealth kill, Just like Dark Souls.
You got a hit on me.
[talking to APC]
It doesn't matter cause we are pickle Rick.
I wish this lens flare would just go away... it's so annoying!
[walks through rock]
Wow. Look at that.
Pickle Rick has his...
...interdimensional rock walking through spell which is great. This game makes me question life...
...and why I'm living it. [sarcasm]
Oh great. We have two lens flares now. Fantastic.
This game made by JJ Abrams?
Stop with the lens flare. My god.
Oh wow. Triple lens flare.
We- we've peaked. Literally if you beat this game...
...it takes 200 plus IQ at least.
At least!
I need to prove that I'm not just some fake Rick and Morty fan. Come on Felix.
There it is!
Just as I remember. [sarcasm]
My god. Finished. Look at- oh wow. Oh the sweet euphoria!
"This is it for now, but we are planning on adding more levels."
Are you kidding me?
You're- you're joking...
Best game! Best game of all time.
Pickle. Rick. Everybody.
That was incredible. I am so glad and aren't you glad too?
[long exhale to achieve 10:00 videos]
[I spent an hour doing this]